hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well so there's a
heart in mimicking ethics go to where he
says what what kind of thing is virtue
and he lays out three different
possibilities he says our virtues
capacities are the potential W you know
what does he mean by that well you know
we have the potential for feeling all
sorts of things and if you don't get
that then there's something lacking to
your humanity there's something damaged
right if all you could feel was fear
anger and
desire then you would be basically at
the level of a snake you would be
lacking something that mammals have the
capacity to feel genuine affection that
you know we can take for granted but you
know our brain develops in different
ways and some people's brains don't to
go a long way and there could be some
certain things in one's operating their
environment that you know push that out
of myself as well but we all have these
capacities based on our human nature and
Aristotle said well tiny nature or
neither good nor bad so we don't start
off automatically good we don't start
off automatically bad some theories of
human nature do see human beings I don't
think but Aristotle doesn't he says
we're not a completely blank slate but
we have these capacities and then a lot
of it depends on what we do it those are
mere potential we also have capacities
for acting in certain ways you know if
you think if you think about anger for
example I have the capacity to hit
people I have the capacity to yell at
people I also the capacity to go off and
you know take ten deep breaths and
compose myself those are all
possibilities for me those are all
things that are part of human nature you
know they're all things that you can
teach a child for example
what about emollients could virtues be
emotions you know for instance let's
think about good emotions what are some
some emotions that we typically see as
as good yeah okay yeah being in a happy
joyful state you know also the opposite
of a person was a downer right yeah LA
right yeah that's that's a real big one
it'll actually doesn't talk that much
about that but he is interested in in
affection and friendship any others that
are particularly I mean yeah happiness
or joy and love yeah being relieved that
that's usually because something bad
didn't happen so it's not completely
positive but that could work too now
when you think about the way people tell
other people to be just be happy be a
nice person to be around
be loving well those would be from
Aristotle's perspective emotions and
those themselves are not they're
positive or negative in the way that we
feel them but they're not morally a
positive or negative it's not like a
person who is loving is therefore
because of the mere fact that they love
I'm a good person in Aristotle's rule
because they could love the wrong things
where they could love the wrong way or
love the wrong people there might
actually be some people that you should
hate from Aristotle's perspective there
probably are some times when you
shouldn't be happy you know
to observe a whole crate full of kittens
drowning
you know the river you probably should
be upset if you're if you're left while
all this is this is great there's
probably something that you want to look
at you know so it's not the emotions by
themselves that are necessarily good at
bad actions are a little bit different
we'll talk about that in a moment so
Aristotle says well what is really good
or bad it's our habits
it's our dispositions it's the way in
which we characteristically over time
because that's part of who we are the
way in which we process and act on our
emotions also to some extent the things
that we love allow or you know seek out
to cause our emotions so he's not saying
that anger you know angered by it salts
neither good or bad I mean if you get
angry all the time over it really simple
stuff that's part of a disposition but
it has to do with how you feel and what
provokes the anger so the anger becomes
bad because of the disposition that
shapes that that feeds a death that
directs that orders goods and these
things you have to be developed over
time we have some degree of control over
that but not you know not the sort of
control where we can just snap our
fingers and now I'm no longer an angry
person now I'm a generous person you
have to actually work on it all the time
so what about a actions now well
Aristotle says if you want to evaluate
actions you can call the actions good or
bad right or wrong
juster unjust but if you want to call
them good in the fullest sense that
you're gonna you're gonna have to make
reference to these dispositions virtues
are good dispositions that
things that make us fully what we are
they make us more rational they allow us
to proceed towards happiness or
flourishing to be good in our home lives
in other people's lives they allow us to
do what we want to do well so to to be
in a good State
there are certain kinds of actions that
are characteristic of that we'll talk a
little bit more about the specifics in a
few minutes
likewise there on the bad side there's
going to be some things that are
characteristic of that as well so
hitting another person that could be a
good or bad action really depending on
what point behind it is if you're on
battlefield and you're defending your
city and your job is actually to go out
there and hit other people with pointed
stuff that's going to kill them and you
do hit another person that's actually a
good act and if you had to do that while
standing up to your fear that that other
guy is trying to run you through at the
same time and you stayed in your place
you're actually doing an action that at
least is in accordance with courage it
might actually come from the full
disposition of courage if you refused to
hit the other person even though your
city is depending on you to fight for it
and nobody else is going to do it and
bad things are going to happen to all
the people that you love because you're
not willing to hit somebody that would
be a bad action that's coming from
Aristotle and say if you want to
understand why that's a bad action call
it the cowardly action if you hit
somebody now let's say we take the
soldier on the picture right here's
walking on the street and walk up to
somebody just pop them in the face
and somebody says why did you do that I
said it was like hitting people I get a
kick out
well Harris let's say there's something
really wrong with you and that that
action is made worse by the fact that
that's a part of your character it's a
bad action at the ginno if they hit
somebody with no provocation but to go
up to people to literally just you know
hit them and do that day after day after
day that's a sign of really bad
character that makes the action worse
try to think of the cases where it could
be different what do you get if you get
the general idea right we evaluate the
actions from a virtue ethics perspective
not just as the actions but as parts of
a larger picture of a person's character
and we could could we be wrong about a
person's character can we misjudge it
sometimes if we don't have full
information yeah but if you observe
people long enough and you've got enough
common sense you know you can tell who
are good and bad people in this sense by
seeing who actually is generous and
who's stingy who actually is a good
friend and who's the bad friend who
betrays their friends who arranges their
life in such a way as to make it
convenient for them and them alone and
who actually takes other people into
consideration right but that's not one
that Aristotle talks much about then you
can understand that as a person as well
so what's really going to matter is did
this level of habitual disposition what
we do is that all that you need for a
thing to be a virtue no there's a bit
more than that but virtues are very much
like other things that we learn over
time like any of you who've ever played
a a sports team and headers
drills you know maybe in high school or
middle school or some of you are
athletes now or any of you who are
musicians what are other things like
this any any on-the-job training that
you can you've had to develop it over
time and eventually it became part of
who you are it became as Aristotle says
second nature right
well virtue works like that as well what
else is needed in order for an action to
be virtuous in order for an action to be
fully good Aristotle says well you have
to be acting I would approach you you
also have to know what you're doing so
you know can you do bad things because
you didn't know the whole situation that
you're in when you're trying to do a
good thing and it may actually have even
come from your good character yeah that
doesn't make you a bad person
likewise are there bad people who do
good things occasionally without
realizing that they're doing a good
thing to somebody else sure it happens
all the time it doesn't mean they're
good people because of them you actually
have to know what it is that you're
doing that's a bit where the situation
that you're at and you have to choose
the action or the emotional response
that you have for its own sake because
it's the right thing can you do all
sorts of things that are good actions
for reasons that don't have that much to
do with in action
yeah I mean you could you can pay me to
tutor you in all sorts of subjects
because I
you know actually tutored a lot of
different subjects is that the same
thing as my volunteering you know
because I care about you as a person to
help you out with your quest for
knowledge no I'm just getting paid right
you wouldn't call the action that I'm
engaging in necessarily a good action if
I'm just doing it to get paid what if I
you know think about you know the
proverbial Boy Scout helping the old
lady cross the street if he's only doing
it to get the merit badge or whatever
does that Boy Scouts get I might mix it
up Girl Scouts get badges did you track
if he's just doing it for the merit
badge is he doing a good act it's a good
Act insofar as it keeps a lady for
getting yeah but it's not a good act in
the sense of coming from good character
yeah like his action it's sort of like
teaching I suppose we do
yes and this is one thing that's a very
good question this is one thing that
Aristotle doesn't make clear enough
sometimes when we do that sort of thing
when we have an extrinsic reward for
avoiding a punishment for doing a
certain kind of action that would be a
virtuous action the person that doesn't
seem to catch up and and you couldn't
rewarding them and they quit doing it so
it didn't become part of their character
yet at the same time the kind of
training that we have to do with kids
has to start with like giving them some
candy or some praise or you know
punishing them for doing something good
and then you know taking something away
and punishing them for doing something
yeah what determines that that sort of
catch you know whether it's going to go
off in the direction of virtue or just
stay at the same level
he doesn't talk very well about that
that is one sort of gap in his his
treatment take something away like isn't
that what he wasn't justice was like if
you hurt them it's a continuing
something like they learned that okay
justice so that you know is it really
yeah if they never understand what
you're doing to be anything other than
an opposing force up right then they're
not they're not gonna progress yeah
and the Aristotle this is kind of a side
note but Aristotle it seems to be kind
of two minds about this if you think
about just his theory in general
he's presuming that by our human nature
we do have the capacity to to get it to
see eventually that oh there's a point
to this besides just punishing me in
practice if you look at the remarks that
he says about ordinary people and about
the way politics works and stuff like
that he seems to be very pessimistic
about this actually happening for most
people he thinks that that the majority
of people are actually and the c-segment
Greeks at his time are actually fairly
untrustworthy not virtue as given to you
know
being very selfish and the only way
you're really going to keep them in line
is by making sure to punish them when
they do the wrong thing or at least
didn't have a lot in place she does say
some things that kind of tie this
together it really helps according to
Aristotle to have the right upbringing
but again this is this is one weak area
if you were around today and he had the
chance to like you know talk on his own
behalf and I think there were there are
some things that you could say it makes
sense what else is this all that's
needed Aristotle also says that you have
to have some sort of criteria some sort
of way of figuring these things out and
what is that going to look like he says
that a virtuous action will be one that
is done in accordance with reason so
it's going to use our rationality it's
going and it's going to be have to do
with the particular case it's gonna have
to figure out sort of specifically
what's appropriate in this case so
reason or another way of thinking this
is is in terms of models you know you
can model yourself after a person who is
virtuous so if you want to develop a
better temper look at people who even
though they do get angry keep their
anger under control and only seem to get
angry at the right time again give way
to their anger
the right time and then you know if you
want to actually become like them look
at what they do look at the way that
they live and then you do the same thing
you emulate them to try to become like
them but eventually reason the in you is
going to work much better and you're
going to be able to figure it out I'd be
wrong but it may take some guidance at
first same thing if you want to become
temperate let's take that as an example
because that's what I think one that's
very easy to relate to what is
temperance or moderation have to do with
bodily desires and what are the big
bodily desires food drink sex I guess
sleep too few other comfort things like
that let's just take food though if you
got yourself into a bad disposition with
respect to food where you eat whatever
you want whenever you want because you
know that's your right and that's the
right thing to do in this society you're
gonna get fat pretty quickly right
because they put so many things out
there for you you don't have any
restraints on your appetite you know I
mean you've all seen all these these
like Fast Food Nation and stuff like
that they will give you as much food as
you can eat and it's up to you they
actually like to be able to say no I'm
gonna I'm gonna hold off on or if you're
gonna eat as much as you want then you
have to exercise right you can't not
exercise you can't eat as much as you
want
what if you want to change that is that
an easy thing to change that's tough and
if you have been on diets you know how
you know diets they're not fun right
you're restraining yourself is it easier
when you've got somebody to look up to
somebody who's been through it somebody
who can say yeah I know what that felt
like but here's what you got to do what
do you think
somebody could probably say that from
experience not necessarily the day out
but with other things as well eventually
you're able to say to yourself this is
the right amount this is what I should
have at this time and eventually
according to Aristotle you'll actually
come to desire this that will become
what feels right to you that menu you
can tell your virtuous with respective
food so that's the general idea virgin